folks jodarossa here what do we got
coming up we got shows in houston texas
on the 19th and 22nd of may we got shows
in austin texas on the 20th and 21st of
may
uh we got the punchline coming up in san
francisco in july and then in september
i'll be coming through to somerville in
the great new england area of the united
states of america uh
some of those tickets are available now
others aren't the ones that are
available you can get at
joedorosainfo.com
as i say this to you go and do that
please the other tickets will be
available soon enough my apologies
uh fort collins in denver is not
happening the club got the dates wrong
and something went sideways so i was out
of my hands and i apologize i'll try to
make it up to all of you as soon as
possible
in the meantime if you're in new york
city come to joey rose's all info there
joeyrosesnyc.com we're open tuesday
through sunday full bar and delicious
sandwiches thank you
what's up taste buddies uh this week i
will be in new york city at the beacon
theater on saturday may 14th in just a
few days and then the next week after
that you can catch me in san diego at
the majestic theater on may 21st and
sunday night may 22nd in los angeles for
the first time at the wilton theater all
tickets available at savocanocomedy.com
so is taste buds merch my merch even hey
bay merch check my website out i'll see
you guys soon taste buds they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
folks welcome to t-a-s-t-e
bud
i gotta do it alone the chant when sally
boy's not here
but we got a great person filling in
here it's emma willman and everybody
thank you joe thanks for having me
welcome to the show appreciate it you uh
you have big shoes to fill
i know shall be gone but i think you're
gonna film just great all right we'll
try i believe in what i'm saying so i
hope that helps yeah when i'm gone it's
small shoes to phil you should you
should you should be filling it for me
it's true far easier fair fair
where is that
sal um sal had kovid oh god he's fine
now at the time of this recording but
because of him having kovid it shifted
when we were able to record and now he's
not available it was a whole thing got
it got it anyway we had to do some
makeup episodes and we did a few with
brian quinn from practical jokers nice
very lovely man good dear friend and and
we're doing one with you
great looking forward to it i've never
been in your apartment before this is
lovely thank you very much it wasn't
what i expected what'd you expect i
don't know
i it was it's this
there's so much light
yes
it's very happy like it's a it's a happy
place and it's very i mean it's it's
well decorated like it's it's it's very
nice thank you i take pride in
in in the in the layout of my apartment
yeah and in the way it's decorated
uh and i also thrive on a lot of light i
agree i feel the exact same way i get
very depressed in my personal life
when i'm not up there on the stage
you're happy
uh i wouldn't say i'm happy
but i definitely lead a lighter much
lighter uh personal existence than
people think
a lot of the brooding and everything i
try to channel it to the stage and to
twitter right and the other stuff when
i'm not on twitter yeah i hate twitter i
hate it that's the place to channel it
yeah i try to put hard opinions there
and then in my comedy
and then everything else i try to you
know it's like i collect video games
like movies i got a hoagie shop you know
try to keep it light yeah you're
well-rounded you know yeah so did you
hear they're gonna charge you money to
use twitter now that's what they're
pitching oh great how much money i'm
glad i don't know it's gonna be like a
toll that's insane is that elon that's
elon that's elon that's that's insane i
bad move i i it i i've been looking for
an excuse to leave
i had a great excuse my account got
hacked and then i just never tried to
get it back
yeah i don't know why i've
i always drift back because actually no
i was off and then i came back because
of this show
because we were doing polls sure
and
sal actually does all the polls usually
so i don't even have to tweet those out
but then i felt like i was kind of
dragging ass by not tweeting every week
that a new episode was out but you know
what pimp [ __ ] it what what good does
that do anyway why don't you just give
us the login what are you doing it for
you know what folks did i think i'm out
i think i'm leaving twitter again i'm
gonna keep the salsa windfall well
that's that's the thing i want to
promote the sauce of windfall twitter
and and it's hard to do without my
twitter also if it's giving you an
outlet to get put your hard opinions out
there and then keep it the rest of your
life like i feel like most most like
famous people just post and ghost like
sure oh yeah don't interrupt you're good
at that me neither i got a little issue
you guys have the itch yeah i get a
little what i do is if i'm feeling bad i
go hunting for things to validate when
i'm feeling bad so i'll go look through
the comments and everyone
sometimes i start going going back and
forth i told someone to eat [ __ ] and die
chew in a razor blade get aids in the
face oh my god and i always go back then
delete them this is what we do
there was one i forgot to delete and my
friend andrew sent me a message and he
was like i saw you wrote back to someone
and i was like what did i say and he
screen grabbed it it was me saying like
go for yourself you're a loser if i were
you i'd kill myself and i was like oh
and then had to delete that because i
can't have that i love what drake did
today some guy was trolling him so he
just followed his wife and the guy was
like i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah
and drake wrote to the guy i just
followed your girl because she probably
needs some excitement in her life
what a flex man i was jealous i was
jealous i never even thought of that god
would have flexed it's amazing it's just
like a it's just like a quick it never
feels it feels good after i do it but
then it's kind of embarrassing
it's you know mike d stefano when he was
still alive
told me don't you love that phrase
when he was alive he told me yeah no you
just say he told me recently yeah
uh no he uh um god i really want
seinfeld there for a second
don't you love this phrase folks the uh
anyway what's the deal um no but he told
me because we used to talk about having
meltdowns on stage because
i used to lose my mind on stage
and he did too and he stopped way before
i did and then eventually i stopped too
but one of the things that got me to
stop was he said to me he goes you never
feel good afterwards and i go dude
you're right when you're in that i
remember mark maron talking had a bit
about getting into a fight with his
girlfriend at the time and talking about
like the argument right and talking
about like he was like you know and you
and if you're one of these people like
me when you get going it feels like good
it's a drug it's the adrenaline pump and
it's not usually about the thing it's
about something else yeah and then like
that's the thing it does feel good and
then there's a huge crash huge terrible
afternoon yeah i mean
i can't tell people that i've now now
that i've i can't tell people to kill
themselves no it's crazy no no cause
you're saying i don't mean that you're
on your way to better things oh i let us
pray
my room telling eight-year-olds to kill
themselves i mean i can't do that
you're you're um you're on an incline
people like you
uh your tick-tock is booming trying
you're doing well like you you have some
good stuff in in your future
i'm
i'm i mean i'm done for it's over
it's it's it's it's no listen i will
still listen goddammit joe so you think
that means then you can just say
whatever you want online
i will still have a career but i will
have a career the way ted nugent has a
career like i'll just be off at some
place putting out records and certain
people go oh the new ted nugent dude i'm
going to film you till you die you think
i'm not comparing myself to ted nugent
by the way that's a friend i don't mean
i don't mean politically i'm like ted
nugent right i just mean like i've i'm
in that phase of my artistry okay
there's never gonna be the big like oh
we got to get this kid into the major
labels now you know like it's that time
has passed um
but i'll still have a nice independent
culture who knows what's going to happen
it's a wild west out here but you know
you you still got a shot you still got
an nbc shot is what i'm saying so like
i'm like not with these comments yeah
that's what i'm saying right here i
think get get get the comments off you
got a real shot at like a sitcom emma
well oh yeah that's what you call it
well that's what they will force okay
okay yeah it'll be called emma
you'll be uh lesbian trying to figure it
out exactly along those lines lesbians
got to move in with their straight
mother
you know some [ __ ] oh my god
straight
you know what she said the other day
she was with the me and my girlfriend
and i forget how it even came up it was
very out of left field she was like
something something something i think
everybody's gay and then she stared off
in the space and i was like that's not
true at all like at all and she was like
no i think everybody you know sometimes
i think about my friends and i wonder
what if and then she stared off again so
i she i hope she's straight i'd feel
weird if she was not wouldn't that be
kind of weird
if your mom was a lesbian yeah it's
weird because she's not i know she's not
but i would feel bad kind i'd feel like
weird like i feel like i did something
wrong like you changed her i don't know
oh boy that's well hey listen
i'm just glad the lesbian is the one
saying that right now
i said that jesus christ
crucified
what would even
i mean it's your mom yeah yeah you know
i feel like anything i say anymore i get
screamed at by people i'm just like
whatever i don't even i was thinking i
was like because sometimes when people
will make comments about how i look on
tick tock or whatever it is i was like
oh this is tough but then i went over to
i think i was on michael class's tic-tac
and he had a really hit a funny joke and
then there were all these comments like
oh great another straight white guy
comment so everyone's just getting stuff
from every angle all the time i got
called a colonist today i don't even
know what that is what
people are oh colonists or colonizers oh
calling the connor is calling but the
thing is those people get the same high
you guys get from telling them off i
never thought of it like that you think
they do oh yeah do you think they get
that much of a rush because i really
i think they do and then they crash and
they have to go shower
like
true i
this is what i love about emma
emma and i were fast friends uh we met
uh at the stand yep
we met at the bar at the stand it was
still when the outdoor shows were going
on
and you're one of those people i met and
immediately we were talking [ __ ] about
somebody being a [ __ ] [ __ ] ah and i
was like wow
she's cool like yes we're gonna speak in
my language that's it we're meeting your
friends absolutely what happened with
maddie smith oh she's great
yeah she's great she's awesome and i
knew maddie like from around we saw each
other we'd talk a little bit but we had
our first like what i thought was like a
real conversation the other day and we
were within three minutes talking [ __ ]
about people
and i said to her go matty
we're we're way down the offend
friendship right now yeah nothing bonds
you quickly talking [ __ ] about other
people but
you wrote this this is why i knew you'd
be great for the podcast too
because i asked you to do it first right
yeah and you said yes because i thought
you'd be good and then you you
reinforced how good you would be because
we talked about
the first thing i always ask somebody is
which what food do you love start naming
some foods that you love so i can figure
out if i hate one of them sure and then
you said goat cheese and i was like
perfect i hate goat cheese and i said do
you like provolone
and you said provolone is special needs
cheese
100
so i was like perfect we're off to the
races that phrase should be on a taste
buds t-shirt
here's something uh here we go going
back into like meeting each other
so
cause i and i always it made me think
when you said you didn't like goat
cheese it made me sincerely feel like i
maybe and i also i was looking at some
old comedy clips too i there you were
doing the i love the joke about cleopat
like eating on your side the taco bell
clear pattern way back but now that i
know you don't like goat cheese i feel
like i miss something because if there's
something so wrong with you to not like
goat cheese i feel like there's i'm
getting hoodwinked by the whole shebang
i'll tell you what let's get right into
the battle and then i come into the
apartment as something i didn't expect
so maybe there's a whole maybe i don't
even know you at all but i think are
many colors to me
but it's weird people don't realize it
that's why i think i get so offended
when somebody sizes me up on twitter
sure particularly when somebody will go
oh you're just x y and z and i'm like
you don't know me you have no [ __ ]
idea who i am you don't want a painted
man
fifty shades of joe yeah fifty shades of
jelly shoes that's the one-person show
we didn't ask for what we need yeah
um i get that though i hate the
assumptions let's get into the battle
okay because i i want to do i don't want
to lose the goat cheese fire okay this
is the chat you don't have to do it with
me i'll just do it
b-a-t-t-l-e
buns here we go go cheese versus
provolone
ms team goat cheese i'm team provolone
and i i will immediately start this
battle by responding to it but you're
crazy you just said that you can't
understand how i don't like goat cheese
yeah goat cheese is disgusting
nobody wants smoke soaking wet cheese
this isn't true it's not smelling wet
cream cheese it's got like a cream to do
like cream cheese
only on a bagel on anything else get it
out of my face not even a cracker no i
love it on a cracker because i love the
i love the crisp of the cracker and the
squish with the cheese and i like that i
like it with smoked salmon oh which is
also a way i like goats that's so
disgusting
that's so disgusting you have always
struck me as somebody that eats
disgusting things really yeah you you
you struck me as someone who would eat
the same type of things that i would no
i always thought
you that what's ever going on because i
i relate to your brain so i would think
i would relate to what's going on in
your mouth and now i come to find out
there's gonna be some disconnect between
your braid and the mouth no no no no you
you strike me as you like you like to
eat smelly thing no
like like like uh like a like uh like a
like a can you you struggle with one of
those people that shoots the canned
cheese into their mouth oh go [ __ ]
yourself joe
that's disgusting is that because i grew
up in maine
i ca first of all i can't believe you
grew up in maine i think yeah you grew
up in chicago this whole time yeah you
have a chicago accent i don't know what
my accent is all i know the only time
people usually comment on the accent is
when i walk it's any time i've
auditioned for a commercial audition the
casting person after about a minute goes
are you from the small town
and
and i i don't that's not a compliment
they don't even it's not even like a
regional thing they just say are you
from a small town but that's usually so
you think i have an accent because i
don't usually sound like even what you
just said every every time i audition
you're selling you're from chicago oh
[ __ ] i don't know but uh but no no i
there's just you know what it is that
day
that now i'm doing it and that day that
you showed me
when you you showed me how much you eat
with your hands i was like he hated it i
was like he hated it what were you
eating with your hands oh dude it was
something that you should not supposed
to eat with your hands like salad or
something
here's the thing when i'm really so i
like to eat with my hands as like a
sensory experience i don't know if it's
an add thing or what i probably can't
blame it on that but it's like i like it
helps me anticipate more what's coming i
guess emma but what you just said the
words you just said i like to use my
hands because it's more of a sensory
experience i'd never wear a condom i'm
sorry if i were a guy
please but um
i'm telling you i'm not exaggerating
this
i have a extensive horror movie
collection over there sure that
statement is literally what the guy in
hostile says no
before he murders people
he's he eats with his hands and he talks
about how it's like this hand like it's
a century experience and then he pays
money to torture people no
yes i swear to you that's like like it's
like you know when they do the flashback
and they're trying to figure out if
they're a science the person was going
to be a serial killer and then someone's
like well they with their hands no yes
it's and because i'm when i'm
comfortable with people i remember that
was late night and we were talking and i
know i was like okay i'm with joe and
two other people i'm comfortable with i
look around so i'm not being a monster
and then i move the utensils to the side
and i eat and everyone else didn't mind
and then he was mortified i take the
dressing and i flip it off so it's not
dripping as i that part is gross too
you're not even like give me the
dressing on the side because i'm going
to eat my hands so i'm going to dip it
you take it and you start flicking it
liking it to get the ratios right
in some cultures that's how you do it
it's so weird it's saying like people
eat with their hands are in better shape
well probably because it's disgusting
you're getting so you don't eat as much
you're getting less food you get dirt in
your mouth from your fingers that's
really interesting i'm kind of surprised
by that i just it makes me feel i don't
know i don't like the i don't like the
fork getting in the way of stuff even
even though and i'm a sandwich obviously
huge proponent of sandwiches but i break
mine up and eat it in chunks i don't
like but my point is is even with a
sandwich
or fried chicken or another hand food
that i love
it's different because there's there's a
distance from hand to mouth you don't
use the fork with
but i'm saying though as soon as you're
holding it here and you're biting here
there's a distance
your thing is like you're taking like
bites of something and putting it into
your mouth it's it really ralps me out
i'm sorry and when i eat a sandwich i
take it i take a like break it off and
then do it the same way oh my god where
did that start years ago i've always
done that i guess after teenager
i guess i think well so i always think
of it i don't know if it's because i
like grew up with my dad but it's not
like he did that but i always and then i
would eat alone a lot as a kid so i
realized like maybe that's where i
started to pick it up but also too
but wait but let's let's apply this now
to the cheese argument you're talking
about you love sandwiches provolone is a
king cheese for a sandwich period
provost pushes in with all the other
things and so it just creates like a
plasticy taste no not a sharp problem
number one not a sharp provolone number
two i don't think you can have a shark
provolone i think that's like like an
oxymoron
what i think a sharp have you ever had a
sharp profile extra sharp provolone it's
going to change your life
in a chatter
how dare you
how dare you no i've never seen your
provolone
you put it a lot on uh antipas or
charcuterie boards really right meats
and things yeah sharp provolone extra
sharp provolone i bet it doesn't taste
that sharp it's crazy sharp because
provolone is a muted it seems that seems
like someone who's like really
mild provolone it'd be like me if i'm
provolone it'd be like me trying to do
math and i wouldn't be good at it so
it'd be like a slow person doing
you know what i mean provo is a slow
cheese
it's it's filled with it's it's a mush
it's and i love monster and i like mushy
stuff but it's just got it's got it's
almost like a plastic problem is so much
more flavor than monster number one
number two sharp provolone is so robust
it's insane number three goat cheese on
the sandwich stinks love it what
sandwich you put in goat cheese i'll
take it i put it with pesto i'll put it
with like a dried tomato i put it with
some salami which cheese is more
versatile do you think uh provolone
might melt better but that's just
because anything to get it out of its
provolone is a thousand times more
versatile provolone has shades there are
shades of prevalent you have extra sharp
sharp you have mild uh they're smoked
provolone goat cheese is goat cheese
babe that's it you put a slab of that
[ __ ] on top of a salad people think that
they're eating a classy salad
it's up charge it's an up charge for
goats oh [ __ ] gross when was the
first time you had goat cheese do you
recall
yes i do um yes i do because i'm a big
blue cheese fan really yeah and i was at
the uh there was a comedy club called
seabees
i remember that comedy yeah yeah it was
in the west village they had goat cheese
at seabees they actually had because
they didn't tell you right upstairs no
no they had a nice italian restaurant
they did and you could order the food
from there downstairs because the same
owner oh i didn't know that so i said
one night i said
this salad is it any good and then see
be the owner she goes there's goat
cheese and when i go i never i go wait
goat cheese i never had go and she goes
it's a selling point
someone wouldn't have provolone headline
a meal
featuring goat cheese
goat goat cheese let's just break down
the name okay goat cheese what good
comes out of a goat when you say it like
that
when you say it with that disdain
anything's gonna sound bad i'm reading
here it depends on the goat's diet with
the cheese oh yeah maybe you had a
[ __ ] goat anything
maybe you had a goat maybe you had some
goat that
was had some kind of urinary tract
infection goats eat anything dude
they'll like a goat will start chewing
on your shirt if you stand but that's
why you have to get maybe you get a goat
from one like a farm where they just eat
honeysuckle or something like that
they're evil looking creatures they
always represent the devil in things in
one way or another
uh that's how good the cheese is it's
satan
provolone you're talking about that
beautiful
give me the history of provolone pimp
give me the history of prevalent
from italy baby from the po river valley
of italy
that's uh it
means globe shaped for whatever that's
worth created in the 1800s what's the
history of goat cheese
so mine's coming out of italy yours oh
god it looks like he's doing something
right
kind of looks like
that's a weird way he's milking that
goat don't usually go to the side why is
he behind him there's only one way to
milk a goat from the back i think that's
the only way you can do it really the
whole
endeavor with this animal couldn't be
disgusting because it looks that looks
very
i don't know if i watch too much it
looks a little sexual sexual yeah all
right yeah it looks nasty the whole
thing looks nasty
i mean you would because i feel like if
you're going to milk something out of
respect for the animal you go to the
side just so it no but okay so they're
going even the little boys milking the
goat from the back that's what you got
to do does it come from they've got
udders it's not like from the
like i think they have others yeah they
have to yeah no they have others do they
pee out of the same place you milk it
i'm still eating the cheese i don't give
a [ __ ] no i don't think so it's it's
they're like cows they have like a milk
thing well that's prey
i think right i mean
ooh goat breeding but wait do you
wait a minute though if you have goats
on a farm do you have to milk them the
way you have to deal with cows like cows
like you have to they right like it's
uncomfortable goats produce about two
percent of the world's total annual milk
supply some go spread specifically for
milk goat milk naturally
has small
well emulsified fat globules okay that
sounds gross but i feel like
okay that is not
it's not i don't know what's a globule
okay i mean it doesn't sound good sounds
like a [ __ ] smells like pulp yeah
like a glop of gross i mean the cow
you're putting a cow i mean q and i last
week
was it last week pimp
uh had such a great talk about cows on
this thing goat ain't got nothing on a
cow dude
smokers i'm talking to you we're gonna
talk lucy
i
was a smoker uh
and i loved smoking
but i will say this there were times
even when i was a smoker that i wanted a
different way to get my nicotine fix
something outside of traditional smoking
just as an alternative method
and that's what lucy is offering it's a
modern oral nicotine company that makes
nicotine gum lozenges and pouches for
adults who are looking for the best most
responsible way to consume their
nicotine it's a new year technically why
not start it out by switching to a new
nicotine product that you can feel good
about you know
even the most hardcore of smokers i
think carry
a certain amount of
i don't want to say guilt but we're
aware that we're sucking smoke into our
lungs and you want to
as i said a more responsible perhaps
slightly healthier method of nicotine
ingestion now i do have to read this
disclaimer
warning this product does contain
nicotine and nicotine is an addictive
chemical so that is still part of it but
if you're interested in a better way to
use nicotine visit
lucy.co
and be the first to use the promo code
tastebuds okay again visit
lucy.c
o and be the first
to use that promo code taste buds for a
better way to ingest your nicotine
folks as the weather gets warmer factor
is here factor one of the newer uh
sponsors here at the taste buds program
they're here to help you spend less time
at home in that kitchen cooking and
grocery shopping and doing dishes and
cooking whatever whatever you're doing
at home with the food or out in the
grocery store with the food they're here
to help you get out and enjoy that sunny
beautiful weather all right factor is
bringing you some beautiful healthy
delicious meal options that you don't
have to prep or anything like that
they're also going to give you some
grab-and-go stuff like smoothies and
juices all right now factor is making it
easy to eat clean 24 7 with fresh never
frozen prepared meals that are so
delicious you wouldn't believe they're
actually good for you feel good this
summer choose from factors
calorie smart and keto friendly options
with built-in portion control it's a
great tool to help you stay fit get fit
whatever it is be fit for the summer i
like the portion control aspect because
i have a tendency to tip scales here and
there
factor offers 30 meals per week where
you can choose from a variety of new
meals every week on top of that they're
giving you the option to change it up
and select any meal plan size between
four to 18 meals per week you got a busy
schedule for both lunch and dinner no
worry maybe you want to add a few meals
they're giving you options folks they're
making it easy for you to eat when you
got
other things you'd rather be doing than
preparing your food and cooking and then
cleaning up afterwards i love this
service each factor meal arrives
pre-prepared and ready to eat in two
minutes that's even faster than ordering
in that's true factor even knows what
preferences you like they're going to
offer you vegan options veggie meals
keto meals low calorie options cold
pressed juices smoothies energy bites
plant-based bars extra protein veggie
size it goes on and on and on all kinds
of stuff to keep you fueled and focused
and the way you need to be so head to
go.factor75.com
tastebuds120 and use promo code
tastebuds120 to get 120 off that's code
taste buds one two zero when you go to
geo dot fac to r75 dot com slash taste
buds one two zero for 120 dollars
cows are more common i feel like a goat
goat cheese i would consider like a
fancier like a special cheese if they
put goat cheese on it's usually extra
well well pimp is goat cheese uh can
look at this goat milk is low
in
calories no it says casein i don't know
what that is that's a protein which is
actually good i thought oh okay so it so
it which so it means it curdles less
actually so it produces a very small
soft curd that crumbles easily i believe
blue cheese is
technically a goat cheese blue cheese i
think is is some kind of they do
something to it doesn't come out just
like but it is not the goat cheese we're
talking about goat cheese and blue i
think part of the problem is your
initial introduction to it was you were
expecting something dramatically
different you know what i mean because
if you're expecting one thing at a taste
then then it would be like bat it would
just your your perception is going to be
skewed i don't like i don't like a
creamy it's the same thing why it's the
same reason when it comes to cheese i
mean it's the same reason why cottage
cheese ralphs me out like the the
texture of it makes me it grows me out
cream cheese for some reason on a bagel
i like but it's got to be a certain
amount of cream cheese if they go too
hard on the cream cheese it grosses me
out yeah sometimes the bodegas go way
too hard it's i mean that's like a
problem this is that makes it is it did
it feels does it feel too decadent to
you do you feel like you don't deserve
it joe
is that what it is
because it's very it's a very like it is
like it's like a royal almost feeling it
gets very
that's not the part of it i don't like
it's it's i don't like how
uh
it's texture it's just
it's like
like i like mayonnaise but when
something has too much mayonnaise on it
it grosses me out right
i can't explain it there's something
about it that just it gets to a certain
point where i'm like this now has become
disgusting i think if you opened up your
mind to goat cheese and you had it just
in like little bits in a salad there's
no way to not like it because you need
to find a way to manipulate the maybe
the um texture of it but if you had it
in little bits it's there's nothing to
not like it's delicious when it comes to
goat cheese i also hate the flavor
but you're wrong here's the thing well
tell me why tell me why the flavor's
good the flavor describe the flavor the
flavor and it can come in the longer
there's something it can be straw it can
be stronger softer so the flavor pairs
so well with so many things and it's
just like it's the perfect amount of
salt the texture is perfect for what the
flavor is so give me some examples
though okay you put it with um sun-dried
tomato it's absolutely delicious but it
was salami it's great the amount of salt
it's better than a provolone with salami
disagree give me a [ __ ] this one they
would charge more
provolone salami to whatever and then
you want it with goat cheese a couple of
dollars more premium vip vip cheese the
uh i could i could fathom a world where
if i had a piece of very crusty bread
and you put the faintest layer on there
like like in the sense that you would
like a butter i love the way that you
can scoop it that does a lot for me too
i like being able to like scoop like
this and not having to cut well you know
because that's a that's a classy food
when scooping is involved
[Laughter]
i love a sk i love is there a fancier
word for scoop like a
no no [ __ ] no
have you ever had your taste buds
checked out
uh
no i wonder what it is that would make
someone because to me goat cheese is
like not it's not like like blue cheese
seems like something that lots of people
would feel strongly one way or the other
about well people do but i also think
people feel strongly about goat cheese i
mean we're going to find out when we go
to the poll at the end of this but i do
think people feel strongly about goat
cheese i i find that most people when i
say to them the one cheese i will never
mess with is goat cheese no way people
are like i guess no way but here's the
thing here's the difference up there
with head cheese which isn't even cheap
but equally disgusting
in my opinion
what the hell is head cheese head cheese
is is congealed meats oh
look it up look up head cheese
revolting here's the thing goat cheese
is gonna either people are gonna love it
or they're gonna hate it but at least it
causes a reaction provolone people are
like give it or take it they're gonna
get it confused with like a soft
mozzarella
[ __ ] that head cheese that's i gotta
tell you i'm not a big fan of of the
much either
i love wow i love mozzarella on pizza i
like it on certain sandwiches melted
raw
fresh mozzarella i get it i understand
you know i i like uh caprese salad
but
but uh you know a lady stopped by the
shop yesterday and started giving me
grief i don't eat here because you don't
put mozzarella on any sandwiches i go
lady over my dead body
she goes oh my god she goes why i go
because i think it adds nothing to a
sandwich and it's incredibly it is an
incredibly short shelf life it's not
worth my time or my money she came to
heckle you and you she just was passing
by outside this lady i'm not stuck in to
say that i was outside when she said it
but i'm not kidding when i say this i
have seen this lady outside of our shop
talking to uh we have an artist out
there lucy who's been painting our
outdoor winnebago space yeah
for weeks she's been painting it i've
seen this woman talking to lucy at least
once a week
every time i've seen it happen i've
heard the woman say why don't they have
mozzarella for anything so she's one of
those like new york ladies that's like
you know i've been in the neighborhood
for 80 000 years and i'm just going to
come by and which is fine i lie you know
sure i love the neighborhood folks it's
great but it doesn't mean that she
doesn't need some fresh material she's
coming by talking mozzarella every year
leave out a little thing of mozzarella
for and tell her to never come back
but i mean it's insane to me that she
won't order a sandwich because we don't
have sure
it's like just get a sandwich without
cheese on it right or go home and put it
on yourself yeah bring your own
mozzarella yeah your own it's a while i
guess that defeats the purpose of the
community
it is if i go like i like white american
cheese on a sandwich but if i went
somewhere and they didn't have it i'd be
like i'll get a different cheese
absolutely or i'll just get something
without cheese on it you got options
yeah i like white american cheese i like
the other i like the colored um cheese
better but that to me i mean that
because that melts really well if you
put goat cheese you like yellow
americans i do like i did this is what i
mean how i knew you were you were like
it's more fun like local it's more fun
now go go cheese go cheese it's uh go my
goat cheese is like american it's like
velveeta and here's the thing i never
had it growing up and my parents never
gave it to me did they give it to you
goat cheese or yellow you're american
they
i think my mom tried to bring it home
once and we were like this is [ __ ] you
get the freshly sliced white american
are you wow that's it individually
wrapped american cheese period is
disgusting tell your own mother to get
out of her own house yeah yeah i mean
policy genius policy genius policy
genius what kind of policies insurance
policies let's talk life insurance
if someone relies on you financially
maybe it's a child maybe it's a parent
maybe it's a business partner life
insurance gives you peace of mind that
they will have the financial cushion
they need if something happens to you
gosh forbid
why get covered now you say i'm young
and this no no no listen typically life
insurance gets more expensive as you age
so it's smart to get a policy sooner
rather than later are you worried about
the pricing of that sort of thing well i
get it but by making it easy to compare
your options from top companies policy
genius can help you make sure that
you're not paying a cent more than you
have to for the coverage you need are
you already covered through work well
having life insurance through your job
may not be enough be aware of that most
people need up to 10 times more coverage
than is provided by their jobs to
properly provide for their families if
something were to happen
you got a big a life event coming up
well let me say this whether you're
graduating from school planning a
wedding welcoming a baby or switching
jobs now is the time
to protect your family's finances so
here's how it works policy genius is
your one-stop shop to find insurance you
need at the right play price your policy
genius so here's how it works policy
genius is your one-stop shop to find the
insurance you need at the right price
you're going to go to policygenius.com
tastebuds to get started that's
policygenius.com
tastebuds to get started in minutes you
can compare personalized quotes from top
companies to find your lowest price you
could save 50 percent or more
off on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius licensed
agents at policy genius are on hand
through the entire process to help you
understand what you're doing what you're
looking at and what you're comparing so
go to policygenius.com
taste buds to get started
my mom would never
she i mean she had like a garden and
she's very into like organic stuff and
then i lived with my dad and he was like
pretty much same thing so we never had
like american cheese growing up so i go
to my friend harrison hines and his mom
would have velveeta okay and it was
delicious so i associate it with like
having fun and like sneaking out and
getting that like cheese all right all
right where did you first have goat
cheese though first time i had goat
cheese i think i was in cape cod okay
and
i think i'm pretty sure i have like a
faint memory of having it on a grilled
cheese sandwich and wondering what kind
of cheese is this
because it was like put with a it was it
was put with a um i think that we had
like a tomatoes and pesto and it was
like a really fancy one and my mom was
like there's goat cheese on it and in
maine i knew people who had got their
own goat cheese
they jerked out they got through they
made their own
like what
they kind of gutted
there's other ways to do that did you
like grow up in a dome or something yeah
i did grow up in a dome my dad's house
was a he built a dome oh that's cool it
is cool he's a mathematician he built
this he was a also a contractor he built
a dome and then it had like an extension
onto it but starting to just think maine
likes goats better than cows
i wonder i mean my dad had before my
sister where i know he had cows i don't
know if he had goats is maine as cool as
i think it is
i romanticize it in my head because of
stephen king sure and i picture like
living in this beautiful farmhouse up
there and just riding all day and you
walk down the street you know your
neighbors and there's a local
kind of cool shop you could go to kind
of get your coffee it's the it's so
remote that there if you there wouldn't
be a coffee shop you could walk to like
in my town there's one coffee shop but
you couldn't walk there like everything
is very spread out and far away from
each other but isn't there like a town
street like a main street there is but
it's not usually within walking distance
from your house i just mean you drive to
the main street then you walk down and
you get your tools for the day yeah
getting your day your day's tools
there's a lady that makes eggs
absolutely there's someone out there
yeah yeah there's like one there's
there's not even a stoplet anymore
there's a roundabout so there's never
any traffic people driving tractors on
the road okay
all right maine's beautiful but it's
very cold i think you would actually
hate it
uh i i am looking for a place to
permanently go
for part of the year wouldn't you want
to be warm though
i thought about that um but i want to i
want to find a place that's the exact
opposite of new york so when i go sure
it's a complete
that's it maine and vermont is like that
maine is is a good choice
people stay in their home like in the
winter it's like there's not a lot of
like community stuff and it's not a
great place for i feel like you're palm
springs i was gonna say or what about
florida
or something definitely not that at all
if you don't like goat cheese you can't
go to pomp's rings i would i would like
uh i i would like i i i wanted i would
like it to be somewhere near some sort
of water like a lake of some kind or a
large pond or an ocean or
something i don't know what about some
place for good tax purposes i don't even
think about it maybe we should really we
should just let the fans vote yeah yes
that's a great idea
in the states or
worldwide options no ins in the country
in the country yeah yeah i mean if you
want water this takes this one out but
new mexico is beautiful
new mexico is beautiful um but it's too
hot i i like as much as i don't want to
go would want to go somewhere ice cold
sure sure it's totally hot either um
it's what stopped me from ever doing it
i love texas but like
the heat aspect of it yeah i don't think
i'd like that would you be comfortable
with the with people the open carry
because in maine beacon people can bring
their guns around i don't care yeah
well what am i going to get a little
shootout what do i don't know
because i feel like if other people had
guns i would want to have a gun and i
feel like then i'd shoot myself
i'd feel i got to be honest in this
crazy world we're living in i feel more
comfortable knowing a guy had like
openly had the gun i trust like okay at
least this guy went through the steps
and i can see he's got one right versus
some loon
packing one in his butt crack
i agree you know yeah yeah i guess if i
knew he went through the steps to have
it then i'd be like much more
comfortable then that would make me yeah
so it's like to me it'd be like to me
it'd be like being in but i'd want a
place where there could be fight club or
a place with like professional wrestlers
put me in the place with the
professional wrestlers at least i think
they kind of understand the power of the
weapon they you wouldn't want it though
if a bunch of other people had it
wouldn't you i'd feel like you wouldn't
feel like emasculated if everyone had a
gun and you didn't have a gun
no i wouldn't care really i would want
to go get a gun and walk around with it
i don't know
who would put some provolone on that
[ __ ] but no i wouldn't feel like
emasculated or anything i think if i
didn't have a gun i'd feel like less i
feel like i'd like to talk to you about
their gun sure oh love to talk about a
gun what an ice breaker and you know
they love to talk about that absolutely
i see you got the winchester absolutely
target yeah yeah what did you have you
went with the 68. yeah yeah i was
looking at that one myself she's a beaut
i was going to get the
the pipe strong have you ever had
whatever [ __ ] the gun models are
called you know when you're making small
talk and you kind of like lie to like
eggman have you ever had something have
you ever had like i remember i was in
maine and i stopped at a farm stand and
i was with someone i was dating at the
time and the person had some type of jam
and i go oh that's a good jam or
something and to get him talk and so we
go back and forth and we got in the car
and she goes have you ever had that gym
and i was like no of course not and she
was like where's the line with you and i
said i'm being friendly
have you had someone call you out for
that because if i saw the gun i would
saying the same thing i go oh you've got
the shotgun i don't seriously date
so i get it i get in the car and it's
just me and nobody's there to judge a
damn thing that i just did right instead
of all the things to pick out that's
your problem with me i'm like you know
it's like
it just i'm just being friendly yeah no
i i agree
i love that i love it you're the best
you're the best let's go to the let's go
to the phones here
uh
we ready for the phones pimp yeah yeah
all right go che this is where we just
read comments great goat cheese might as
well be called ash cheese
i feel like there was a bad batch of
goat cheese that went around someone had
to take a lactate pill just to read this
tweet that's very funny goat cheese is
the provolone what joe de rosa is to
chris to stefano both make me gag but
i'd still put provolone in my mouth
before i dare touch goat cheese damn
wait which wait who's going away
who's going in jake's mouth goat cheese
is me or krish i think i am
go oh you're goat cheese in this
both make me gag but i'd still huh if
i'd eat goat cheese i'd have the same
face that chrissy made that time
provolone is an american staple but if
you go anywhere in the world including
india with a billion people they all eat
goat cheese don't forget the episode of
full okay full house had an episode on
goat cheese wow
uh listen to this person what is this
poll i said the same people it's a show
where we argue food what is this paul
my god almighty what do you
what are you not understanding nothing
ever good came from a goat if you choose
goat they should be uh they they should
tie you up in the streets i bet derozan
picked ghosts i am shocked i am so
surprised by this to me it's like it's a
no-brainer i i you know there's so few
things that i like stand behind really
really strongly but i just like i feel
that i'm right about this
the uh i think you're well i think
you're i don't know
goat cheese is not one of my favorites
but provolone may be the worst cheese of
all time
almost no flavor almost no creaminess
just terrible emotional exactly no
flavor but hold on a second emotions the
reasons don't have creaminess that this
person sure that's why this is a special
option i don't like when people don't
make a point like this where they make
it sound as if all cheeses have
creaminess except a few creaminess is
the
most cheeses
are are
it's a degree of firmness
a creamy spreadable cheese is a minority
cheese it's a minority chew so how come
you don't like minorities joe
i know sal is picking goat now sorry not
today i already commended on i'm sorry i
already commented on joe's poll but god
damn this question pissed me off goat
cheese is either pretentious it is a
little pretentious
oh my god
what they don't know is i just i was at
the dentist this morning getting my
[ __ ] tooth reattached because one
i've been having teeth problems all
summer wow
wow you know what you know what let's
give the wind to that one pimp because
just for the insight that
team goat cheese was getting her teeth
fixed how did she recording
uh and then this person called it it is
pretentious it is a little bit of a
pretentious cheese for a reason
follow at rug it up customs on i i'm
sorry that's
their handle is at
dylan geronimo at dylan geronimo
underscore it's a little bit of a
pretentious cheat it is a little bit of
a pretentious cheese all right here's
where we go to the vote now here's what
happens here you plug now before we go
to the final vote
and then we get the final vote whoever
wins has to say i still love you okay
we're at 8 000 votes for today almost 9
000 not too shabby what are your plugs
my
things coming up yeah i'm gonna i keep
everything on my website at i am
emmawelman.com and i'm on tour all over
i'm gonna be in portland oregon denver
colorado dc and on tick tock at i am
emma wilman
uh guys joderosa comedy on twitter and
instagram as you know he'll uh
as you know houston show coming up be in
san francisco in july tickets for that
go on sale soon coming to somerville in
september and bust in one show for there
and some other stuff happening and also
go to joey rose's uh
get all the info about joeyroses at
joeyrosasnyc.com all comedy tickets
available joe
joederosa info.com and also taste buds
merch is out and emma has a podcast with
matteo oliver
you have a i got a podcast with matteo
lane and
it's called inside the closet great
all right folks here we go to the pole
oh my god i am shocked i'm so surprised
i'm you i'm a pretty like basic like i
like the things that i like i feel like
are you like i like the cheesecake
factory i like watching lawn horse
special victims unit i like watching
porn and i'm trying to live my life i
like things that that that link in with
what a lot of people like food
look at you look at you your feet on the
couch oh my god coffee on the couch this
is everything i'm saying is being
illustrated
i'm a mess no doubt absolutely
i'm not contesting that i'm i'm sloppy
and my tooth has been in and out of my
face
anyway
that's the number 79.7 to 20.3 provolone
wins that's a much needed win for me on
this show all right i totally respect
that i still love you babe likewise
thanks joe
taste buzz they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds